>> That's a smart answer David.
Recall that originally I had said that I'll explain structural similarity, and
I have not done it so far. I'm going to use the spherical example and
David's answer to explain it now. Given the solar system as the source case, and
the atomic structure as target problem. We can see that there is little semantic
similarity between them. The kinds of objects that occur in the solar system
are not at all like the kinds of objects that occur in the atomic structure.
We can also see that pragmatic similarity is not a major issue here. We're not
talking about the goal of the solar system or the goal of the atomic structure.
Although we might have the goal of understanding atomic structure in the solar
system, there is nothing in the solar system, or in the atomic structure,
which has a goal. Yet, David was able to answer this question correctly.
This is because of structural similarity. Let us consider the top part of
the model of the solar system. You can think of this top part like a graph.
The vertices in this graph, correspond to objects and their properties.
The edges in this graph correspond to relationships, such as force between Sun
and Planet. Or, Sun attracts Planet, and Planet attracts Sun. Once again,
this graphical representation of the model atomic structure.
The words are representing the objects and the features. And the edges
are representing the relationships between the objects. Although there's little
semantic similarity, or pragmatic similarity between the two situations,
we can see a structural similarity. A similarity in the structure of the graphs.
Because this part of the graph of the representative of the solar system.
The similar this part of the graph of the representative of the atomic
structure. We can differ infer that we can transfer this part of the graph
of the solar system to infer this part of the graph of the atomic structure.
Structural similarity then captures relational similarity.
What is common between these two situations is neither the objects or
the goals. Where as common here as the relational similarity, and
that is what structure similarity captures.